hi mystery recapped here today I'm going
to explain an American anthology horror
show called The Haunting Hour spoilers
ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
Lily carbo is a spoiled seven-year-old
girl who is known for throwing
unnecessary Tantrums if she doesn't get
what she wants as a result her dad Henry
always provides her with the latest toys
despite being on a tight budget her mom
Jill however believes that they are
giving their daughter too much freedom
and that is why she's become so arrogant
as of late Lily also has an elder
brother Brayden who is caring but strict
in nature even he thinks that the little
girl is not being dealt with properly
can't spank her since it's not the 70s
anymore so guess we're gonna have to
kill her in the opening scene Lily can
be seen anxiously waiting for something
it turns out that she has ordered a
life-sized doll from a popular company
called really you her dad Henry has
spent a whopping one thousand dollars on
it because of which the other members of
the family are not happy Coulda got a
psvr too for that after a while the
delivery finally arrives and Lily is
over the moon to learn that the doll
looks exactly like her she becomes even
more happy when the really you employee
so says that she and the doll Sylvia can
go to the salon and have their hair done
however the parents are less than
ecstatic as the employee reveals that
the salon triple set them back a further
three hundred dollars could have had the
VR charging station and some games too
for that nonetheless for the sake of
their daughter's happiness they agree
Jill even decides to accompany the
little girl making sure that she has the
perfect day however once they reach the
salon Lily starts acting up again she
rudely talks to her hairdresser and even
orders her mom around meanwhile the doll
Sylvia is creepily staring at the mirror
it is evident that something is up with
her as the days pass Lily spends more
and more time with the doll she eats
plays and even sleeps with it her family
finds it a bit alarming but they decide
not to intervene for the time being
thinking she will soon get bored of it
one day a bunch of friends show up at
Lily's home with their respective dolls
they are impressed by the life-sized
doll and congratulate Lily for it
however the Arrogant brat doesn't take
it well she instead starts to be ready
her friends for having cheap and useless
toys just then one of the friends says
that her doll communicated with Sylvia
the latter apparently does not like Lily
and wants to get away from her hearing
this Lily becomes so angry that she
snatches her friend's doll and rips it
in half in the next scene Jill learns
about the incident and angrily storms
inside her daughter's room all these
years she has held herself back and
always turned a blind eye to Lily's bad
attitude but now she has had enough Jill
scolds her daughter for being a reckless
girl and then takes the doll away saying
it was a bad idea to get it in the first
place as expected Lily is enraged by the
punishment so she starts throwing stuff
around meanwhile Jill takes the doll to
her room and stares at it creepily for
no apparent reason she starts liking
Sylvia and even gives her a warm hug
from that day onwards the two become
Inseparable they sleep dine and dance
together her family finds it a bit odd
but Jill could care less after years of
stress she has finally found a friend
he can relate to she's finally on the
path to becoming a brony one day as the
family is having dinner together Lily
innocently asks if she can have the doll
back however Jill angrily brushes her
aside at this point she has stopped
caring about her own daughter once the
parents are done having dinner they get
up and head to the other room leaving
Lily alone with Sylvia the next second a
loud scream is heard and when the
parents rushed to check they find that
someone has spilled chicken gravy on
Henry's laptop unsurprisingly everyone
points at lily as she was the only one
at the table but she keeps on saying
that she didn't do it according to the
little girl it was the creepy doll that
suddenly came to life and smacked the
container however Jill angrily scolds
her for lying before grounding her for a
week that ought to teach you to spill
chicken gravy later Brandon visits his
little sister and politely asks if she
did it when Lily asserts that it was the
doll he becomes suspicious and decides
to keep an eye on it at midnight Henry
covertly grabs the doll from his wife's
grasp and trans reports it to Lily's
room he believes that the little girl
has faced enough punishment already and
it's time that she has a friend back
however the next morning when he wakes
up he again finds Sylvia in his bed all
right you sleep with you
Henry is a bit weirded out but he lets
it go assuming that his wife brought it
back one day as the parents are out Lily
tries to reconcile with the doll at this
point her attitude is completely changed
and she is no longer The Arrogant kid
she once was Lily sneaks into her
parents room to find the doll but to her
surprise it isn't there then she starts
looking through the entire house and in
the corridor she strangely finds
Sylvia's clothes scared the little girl
rushes to inform her brother about it
but he is too occupied playing video
games what a nude to distract your mind
Lily heads downstairs and prepares some
lunch for herself but as she is about to
eat it she feels a slight pain in her
head and passes out a while later she is
woken up by her mom who again scolds her
for being careless Lily slowly comes to
her senses and gets taken aback when she
finds out that she has paint marks all
over her hands shortly after Jill heads
to her room and immediately starts
screaming it turns out that someone has
painted the words bad girl on the wall
once again Lilia is the obvious culprit
and despite her best efforts to claim
otherwise she is reprimanded Brandon is
the only one who knows that his sister
is innocent hence he teams up with her
to find the actual truth about the doll
later they hide a camera inside their
parents room hoping they can catch the
supernatural doll red-handed the plan
works and the doll's movements are
captured on camera that night however
Sylvia appears to be too smart to fall
for these tricks she also knows that a
camera is nothing without its memory
card so she takes it out before going
back to sleep the next morning Brandon
checks the camera and is shocked to find
that its memory card is missing he asks
his mom if she took it but the latter
only becomes angry saying that now her
children have started invading her
privacy Braden tries to explain that he
was doing it to record the doll and this
leads to an argument between the two
meanwhile Lily who is witnessing
everything from nearby suddenly feels a
sharp pain in her head and Falls
unconscious again wasting no time Jill
rushes her to the hospital to get her
checked up on it meanwhile Braden and
his best friend Steve decide to dissect
Sylvia and find out more about it they
suspect that it is a motorized doll
which is being operated by a remote
control however when they remove
Sylvia's head and check inside it is
completely Hollow not a single trace of
wires or any other electrical device is
there although the Revelation is scary
Braden still doesn't give up he knows
that if he observes the doll properly he
will find a clue he starts with the head
and gives it a few rubs to clean the
dust to his surprise he finds the words
destroy the doll written on it this
implies that whoever created Sylvia knew
that it was dangerous they were also too
lazy to destroy themselves elsewhere at
the hospital the doctor conducts a few
tests on Lily and finds that she is
perfectly fine she is simply suffering
from a minor flu which he believes will
go away in a few days back at the house
the boys decide to find the origins of
Sylvia to understand it better so they
embark on a journey to the really you
shop where hundreds of similar dolls are
made Brayden and Steve covertly enter
through the back door and reach a dark
basement where they find some creepy
porcelain heads suddenly an elderly
woman catches them and brings them out
she reveals herself to be Maya the
creator of these dolls the boys then
pull out the picture of Sylvia and
seeing this Maya is shocked she
nervously explains that she did create
the doll but it suddenly became
possessed and that's why she labeled
destroy the doll on it however
unbeknownst to her the company painted
over the words and sold it to an
unfortunate customer which turned out to
be Lily after revealing the entire story
Maya tells the boys to destroy the doll
as soon as they can because if they fail
several innocent lives may be lost back
at home Sylvia frames Lily One More Time
by shattering a mirror this time a
furious Jill doesn't even listen to her
she simply takes the doll away and
closes the door Lily tries going after
her but suddenly she falls to the ground
to her horror one of her legs has turned
into a prosthetic one just like that of
sylvius the next second her entire body
transforms into a doll now Lily cannot
even move an inch the worst thing is
that Sylvia has taken her place she has
now become Lily shortly after the boys
arrive and notice that Lily has
completely changed she is now a happy
and cheerful girl who has miraculously
developed a passion for cooking the
parents easily buy the doll's deceit but
Brayden knows that something is wrong
that night the evil Sylvia secretly
takes Lily outside the house and Shucks
her in the bin the next morning after
Sylvia leaves for school the boys spot
the doll in the Dustbin they again check
it out and find out that it has a
strange mole which wasn't there before
soon Jill also arrives and when she sees
the mole she is taken aback it turns out
that Lily has a birthmark at the exact
same spot but they never mentioned that
to the company this finally makes Jill
realize that the girl who is pretending
to be their daughter is actually an
imposter she breaks down in tears saying
that she has been a terrible mother over
the last few months meanwhile the boys
start looking for Sylvia and eventually
find her near the road the evil doll
also realizes that she has been exposed
so hence she starts running away
meanwhile Jill hugs her lifeless
daughter and starts reminiscing about
the lovely times they spent together
surprisingly this act of affection
brings Lily back to life and on the
other hand Sylvia reverts back to her
doll form as the boys watch from a
distance she tries getting up but
suddenly a large vehicle runs over her
seemingly finishing her off however at
the end of the episode we learned that
Sylvia is still alive she is now ready
to find her next victim and continue her
reign of terror subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching